[Music]
good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight Homeland Security Secretary
Kerstin Nielsen submitted her
resignation over the weekend nielsen
always seemed like a nice person we just
had her on this show last week and she
was nice but it's possible that she was
never really a good fit for the job that
she had her views and immigration always
seemed better suited for a say Jeb Bush
administration during Nielsen's tenure
total deportations were lower than under
Barack Obama the border itself went from
troubled to chaotic to completely out of
control there now more than a hundred
thousand illegal arrivals showing up for
Mexico every month now Kristin Nielsen
didn't single-handedly cause any of
these problems unlike so many in
Washington she didn't push for open
border she didn't seem to believe in
open borders she seemed to believe in
the law but even that was too much for
the left Nielson was denounced as an
extremist and chased out of restaurants
today as she left the White House the
morons on TV were making her sound like
dr. Mengele for the rest of her life
people will look at her and think oh
that's the woman who put children in
cages that's the woman who broke up
families across the border and you know
what they'll be right she sold her soul
because she did become the face of
separating babies from their parents
Nielsen will be known for implementing a
cruel policy so for the year and a half
she spent running the Department of
Homeland Security Kirsten Nielsen should
never sleep soundly again hours after
her resignation of Bloomberg reporter
called Jennifer Epstein tweeted this
quote Nielsen's next stop will be
carefully watched if any major companies
hire her pay her to speak etc expect to
see major outcry from immigration and
civil rights groups and beyond unquote
in other words for her sins Kirsten
Nielsen shouldn't be allowed to have a
job
she must be carefully watched by the way
anyone who disagrees with that
assessment shouldn't be allowed to work
either or speak in public or post on
social media or sell books on Amazon or
use banks that's their position it is
the definition of extremism anyone who
disagrees with me must be hurt this is
not sustainable
deep down pretty much everybody knows
that
can't keep living like this with a small
group of unhappy angry people in power
terrifying the rest of us it is too
stupid and cruel and dishonest countries
have borders that's why there are
countries saying that isn't hate speech
it's true
Barack Obama must not be on Twitter
because whatever has many faults that is
still obvious to him listen to what
Obama said the other day during his
speech in Berlin I worry sometimes when
as we think about how to deal with the
immigration issue we think that any
moves towards assimilation of the
existing of newcomers to the existing
culture is somehow betrayal should we
want to encourage newcomers to learn the
language of the country they're moving
through of course does that mean that
they can never use their own language
no of course that it doesn't mean that
but it's you know it's not racist to say
if you're gonna be here then you should
learn the language of the country that
you just arrived at assimilation is
essential to national cohesion
immigrants should learn the language
doesn't sound crazy by the way nobody's
doubted that in the two hundred forty
year history of these this country least
of all the millions of immigrants who've
arrived here and immediately learned to
sing the national anthem in English it
was self-evident to them and to everyone
else only under the reign of the modern
left has it become forbidden to say what
is true about immigration in a hundred
other topics but the truth itself has
not changed it won't hysteria doesn't
make facts disappear immigration can be
a great thing for a country but it must
be carefully and thoroughly managed you
can't just change a population of a
whole country in the space of 50 years
and assume things will get better if you
cared about a country you wouldn't try
to do that even Bernie Sanders
understands it
at his core Sanders is an old-fashioned
leftist he wants bigger more generous
welfare benefits that may or may not be
a good idea but it definitely will not
work with open
boar's it is impossible with open
borders Sanders acknowledged that the
other day if your point as you open the
borders my god you know there's a lot of
poverty in this world and you're gonna
people from all over the world and I
don't think that's something that we can
do it this way I can't do it there's a
lot of poverty in this world Bernie
Sanders acknowledges the poor will move
here and we're gonna have to pay for it
my gosh Sanders must be racist to say
something like that maybe he just cares
about what happens to America all of our
leaders should care what happens to
America we don't elect them to improve
Mexico or China or Europe
no offense against those countries we
put them in office so they will look out
for this country and us how would you
feel about your parents if they treated
you like Camilla Harris wants to treat
the United States keep the doors
unlocked anyone can stay sleep in your
bed eat your breakfast nobody's keeping
track of how many come and go or who
they are your parents aren't around to
supervise they're over at the neighbor's
house bragging about what good people
they are that's what neglect looks like
it's abuse and that's exactly what's
happening right now people know it look
at the polls Americans would like to see
less immigration into this country not
because they're bad people because
they're people they want the immigrants
we do take to be skilled enough to
support themselves and to contribute to
America right away not three generations
from now more than anything Americans
want secure borders but they're not
getting any of that and so resentment is
building and why wouldn't it so what can
be done to fix it